hey everybody welcome to Gamescom 2014
i'm with mark and we just seen the
tomorrow children mark I'm confused like
what is this game no this was the thing
about this game so it was announced at
the Sony press conference and frankly it
came up it looked really cool
interesting but what the hell okay what
the actual house it's not through like a
twenty five minute presentation and it
looks like some sort of and like
communist Russia act they after the Cold
War simulator where you build towns yeah
this this game is a mix of loads of
stuff right I mean this this this all
blurs lots of genres together which
makes it really difficult to describe
but the story behind the game is it's
post sixties Cold War what's happened is
an experiment has gone wrong and it is
wiped out pretty much the whole
population and has turned the world into
this big white voice like a blank canvas
basic yeah exactly and what's happened
is the people that are left they've been
taken over by this Marxist state and
it's your job to work for the state to
build up cash and money to do more
things for the state and to rescue the
people that are trapped in the void yeah
these people that are trapped in the
void are trapped inside these little
Russian dolls and you rescue them and
you ultimately have to build up the
population of your town that's the goal
basically like it's multiplayer so
you're in the game with up to like fifty
or hundred people yes the same town
within the same time but it's you know
heating with other with other times
right so yeah you're building a tear and
other people buildings home but it's not
multiplayer in the sense like journey
where there's the people are in your
game or this one other person is like
these people are in your game but you
only see them if they're mining or doing
an activity and they appear is this
almost like halo there's like red bard
version of themselves and then as soon
as they stop doing activity they
disappear so it's not like you can it's
not like you see hundreds of people
walking around yeah it's this weird sort
of synchronous / asynchronous
multiplayer but it's just weird but like
you see yeah like you say you see their
actions they appear as like these little
red sort of silhouettes doing things and
you can actually communicate with them
in certain ways as they were mentioning
like a whistle you cancel
them you can do various things the idea
is is that in the voyage where all these
people are and where they're all trapped
is that these islands of here these
little islands can be told anything they
can be one example we were shown was
this giant head there just materialized
out the floor and there procedurally
generated but not totally randomly
there's like an element of sort of
design is a human touch to them and you
go out and you mind them and this is
where the sort of Minecraft these sort
of element is but it's not minecraft
like it's Nikki we saw the mining and
you like mine to reveal stairs it's not
like you were physically choosing
exactly what to put yes we're not
constructing things you'll you're sort
of demolishing things so you sort of
mind through and you can get stairs and
if you might into an object one of these
islands there are resources in there
that you gather all people to rescue and
then you take them back to the town and
then you use those resources to build
your towns path and then all your
actions as well was the other thing
that's part of this is for your marks of
state is that all your actions are
recorded and then at the end of the day
you go to the state place I forgot what
it was called about like the state
employment office yeah it lists all your
actions that you've done for the day and
then you get giving - well you get given
rash rations rich for the boxes okay and
then you get given those and then you
can use those rations to buy new
equipment like better pickaxes which let
you mine faster or weapons and there are
weapons in the game like rocket
launchers was one we saw there's a
jetpack and those are to fight off
monster monsters which one I think is in
this game see it's a really difficult
one to explain hopefully we've tried to
communicate what it is but it's like
elements and minecraft elements of like
like simulation games like SimCity are
things like that yeah it's very cool
very confusing but I am definitely
looking forward to great well if you
want to find out more about this game
then make sure you stay tuned to gain
spot we're gonna have loads of stuff
from Gamescom 2014 so stick with us